also wenn ich mir jetzt auch noch im
namen pax4 verstoße ich also auch nicht
gegen die regeln praktisch krass ey was
geht ab und jetzt willkommen bei einem
neuen video ja da hätte ich hoffe
natürlich euch jetzt gut an die die sich
jetzt fragen alte das sieht ja ganz
schön brutal aus hier finde ich
irgendwie auch ich bin beim joggen
folgen sonst gelaufen der hier so raus
irgendwie ich weiß auch nicht wie das
passiert ist hätte glaube ich auch ins
auge gehen können ist es zum glück nicht
auf jeden fall war es so voll vertieft
in meinem lauf hatte meine mütze auch
auf bisher und dann kam plötzlich
einfach so ein acht punkte deswegen also
macht euch keine sorgen sie bisschen
brutal aus ist es eigentlich nicht
herzlich willkommen zu diesem video
ihr fragt euch was machen wir heute
eigentlich ich hab ja im letzten jahr
öfter mal so 24 stunden challenges
gemacht und ende dieses jahres habe ich
an ein video gemacht wo ich gesagt habe
junge leute in zukunft kommen mehr
wahrscheinlich so produktvideos ich will
nicht mehr so das machen was ich früher
die ganze zeit durchgezogen habe weil es
einfach nicht mehr so zu 100 prozent zum
mit pastor jetzt kam mir auch einige
produktvideos und ich möchte das ganze
ein bisschen mehr struktur noch rein
bringen
deswegen habe ich mir noch ein weiteres
format ausgedacht oder was heißt
ausgedacht eigentlich würde ich nur
weiterführen und zwar könnt ihr euch das
gerne im kalender markieren
ab jetzt gibt es jeden dienstag um 19
uhr auf einem kanal eine 24 stunden
challenge ihr könnt gerne auch weitere
ideen dafür in die kommentare schreiben
auf jeden fall kommt das jetzt noch so
zu meinen
video konzept hin zu sagen das war so
und wir starten direkt mit was echt
interessante es geht nämlich um 24
stunden gefängnis essen ich hab das
schon ein sehr langes gespräch geführt
mit jemandem der mal im gefängnis saß
über ein jahr sogar 15 jahre und er hat
mir so ein paar einblicke gegeben was
ist da wirklich zu essen gibt das will
ich euch nicht vorenthalten
wir haben wirklich 20 30 minuten darüber
gequatscht wäre das natürlich ein
bisschen kürzen wenn ich kein bock auf
das gespräch habe er hat auch ein paar
infos erzählt die finde ich ganz
interessant waren also es lohnt sich das
ganze mal anzuhören dann wenn ich euch
jetzt hier eine minutenzahl ein wo das
video losgeht aber ich kann euch nur ans
herz legen
checkt auf jeden fall war das gespräch
ab hat mal kurz rein und dann könnt ihr
entscheiden ob ihr das gibt was geht was
auch ich habe ja gerade schon
geschrieben und so ich mache also
youtube-videos weist der catwalk ich
mache so eine sonne ist format jetzt so
dass man schon ein bisschen länger
da gibt es also um 24 und talent ist und
die challenge die jetzt ansteht ist halt
24 stunden gefängnis essen essen meiste
und da habe ich jetzt halt an dich
gedacht ob du also ich mache eine
schlimme raus und so also die verzählt
ob du den nicht mal kurz erklären kannst
was man da so zu essen kriegt halt für
mich so ich natürlich kann man sich das
ein bisschen vorstellen aber ich glaube
man kann das ja am besten sagen wenn man
das mal so miterlebt hat und kannst ja
einfach mal irgendwie loslegen morgens
mittags abends oder ich weiß nicht wie
also ich wie gesagt ich verstehe deine
stimme
obwohl vielleicht so wenden wenn wir
jetzt wenn die leute also wenn du das
sagen willst du das interessiert ja
wahrscheinlich jetzt sicher hätte die
zuschauer in den ganzen tag machen das
wirklich so scheiße voranbrachte
sobald aber nicht gemacht
die meisten scheinen da kannst auch
aussuchen hatte konnte sogar anderen
große auswahl
da scheint er dabei oder frust in der
unterschiedlichkeit nicht alles auf
einer stadt das wasser ist oder später
dann herzlichen 11.30 und natürlich eine
journalistenfrage einer kantine
das eröffnet
denn du sagst das essen ist ist nicht
schlecht also ist okay sogar das hat
sich ja für mich jetzt mal gar nicht so
schlecht also ich hab jetzt etwas
schneller das erwartet weise so hallt
das ist immer brot gibt und dann
vielleicht nachmittags irgendwie alle
habe und tatsächlich mit einem einkaufs
kaufen und essen bestellt worden oder
ausländische stars dafür steht auch ein
luxus praktisch dass er gar keine stärke
fällig straffe programm startete das
erste mal dass ich in einer studie weist
auf die qualität an den start gebracht
also wenn ich mir jetzt auch noch
nachmittags eine pepsi 14 verstöße ich
als auch nicht gegen die regeln
praktisch gut ja dann wird
für mich heißt es jetzt einkaufen
ich war wirklich so ein bisschen
überrascht wie das ganze so abläuft und
was sie dazu essen kriegen aber gut
wir gehen mal los
[Musik]
leute was geht ich bin vom einkaufen
wieder da und ich zeige euch einfach mal
was sie gekauft und will ich in der
kamera ich mache heute 24 stunden
erlernt wie im gefängnis ja ich habe
eben mit jemanden gesprochen der
eineinhalb jahre im gefängnis
ganz wichtig wir haben kartoffel das ist
da wohl gang und gäbe dafür ist man
immer kartoffeln dann habe ich ja
gefragt wie nur kartoffeln und zu den
kartoffeln kriegt man glücklicherweise
auch so ein bisschen brokkoli oder
grünkohl dazu deswegen habe ich noch nie
selber gemacht wie immer gleich noch
gleich ganz stark gemäss haben wir hier
wirklich ich hasse dieses boten aber
stumpf ist vollkommen saftiges
vollkommen sagt co
das hat sich zum teil gehört meine
vorstellung von gefängnis war ja dass
man den ganzen tag nur brot und wasser
kriegt oder das ist nicht so also
morgens kann man sich aussuchen ist
jetzt auch kaffee weil sie so wenig
möchte ich glaube nicht doch kannst du
dir kaufen
du kannst dir arbeiten und du kriegst du
geld und einmal in der woche kommt so
ein typ designkiosk kannst du dass pepsi
die kaufen kassen eine deutschen
gefängnissen geht um mich dann ein
bisschen selber zu belohnen habe ich
ihnen eine normale pepsi mitgenommen
jetzt denkst du dir wahrscheinlich als
wenn es im gefängnis pepsi gibt gibt es
doch und hier so ein bisschen wasser ab
heute man muss sagen wir noch jetzt
leider schon mittag das heißt es geht
bis zum morgen mittag mir wurde gesagt
maximal vier scheiben brot gibt es zum
frühstück deswegen fangen wir erst mal
dein zeug haben wir sehr gerne an
nämlich mit diesem rand im gefängnis
können sie da auch nicht so sehen nicht
mit diesem rand
nutzer können wirksam gefängnis kannst
du dir schon aus selber kaufen oder
stubsi london starten schönen tag später
soweit ich habe gerade erst mal schön ja
hallo schafstall mutter ich musste
gerade erst mal googeln wie man dann
überhaupt brokkoli zubereitet ist echt
leicht so aber habe ich halt vorher noch
nie gemacht es ist jetzt nämlich abend
und wir sind laut gefängnis jetzt im
mittagessen wurde mir zumindest gesagt
dass ich immer mittags ein warmes essen
kriegen aber bei uns verschiebt sich das
halt so aber bei uns verschiebt sich das
halt ein bisschen weil ich erst mittags
angefangen hat das ist die einzige warme
mahlzeit jetzt für mich heute
also ich habe heute morgen auf nur noch
mal gefrühstückt halt so ein bisschen
brot und so und ich habe auch wirklich
hunger deswegen fangen wir mal an ich
hoffe man kann es dann ganz gut essen
[Applaus]
so die kartoffeln haben wir schon ein
bisschen geschielt und rein geschnibbelt
aber diese bruch und die stücke jetzt
auch einfach mal dazu also an alle
hausfrauen wenn ich irgendwas falsch
mache schreibt sie an die kommentare
aber das ist mir durchaus bewusst jetzt
kommt noch etwas hinzu und ich würde
sagen wir sehen uns irgendwann gleich so
das sieht aber lecker aus leute und
meine pepsi die gar nicht mehr jetzt
auch mal oder zumindest einen ersten
schluck davon jetzt bin ich wirklich mal
gespannt ob man sowas halt einfach mal
so runter kriegt eigentlich schon also
ich muss sagen es gibt schlimmeres ne
leute leider ist die kamera leer ich
musste kurz laden damit ich wieder ein
bisschen akku hab ich muss sagen
wahrscheinlich haben die da ja ein
bisschen soße dazu dass ich möchte jetzt
wirklich nicht gut so aber es gibt halt
vollvisier und natürlich waren so was
jetzt ein jahr jeden tag kriegt die
haben es ja nach dem dritten tag
wahrscheinlich aus den ohren raus buch
ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu sehr
durch warschau fahren könnten noch mal
schön lange aber ich kann halt einfach
nicht kochen und die plötzlich ist
richtig was also wenn es so war es dann
auch noch dazu gibt steckt mich gerne im
knast kein ding schon manchmal youtube
nicht mal deutschland eine bank
ausrauben und wenn ich das nicht schaffe
kann man machen wenn man das dann nicht
schaffen gut gehalten jahren knast pepsi
schlüpfen
wir messen und 2 uhr morgens und ich hab
hunger also wird er ist jetzt mal nix
aber man erwarten dass man abends genug
ist also wirklich voll ist kann dann
morgen so
ich bin gerade aufgestanden war duschen
moment und ich habe wirklich eigentlich
nichts mit der kamera gemacht aber hier
bei mikrofon fehlt einfach das denn die
glaube heute nacht waren geister in
meinem zimmer leute auf jeden fall
weshalb 10
ich bin jetzt gleicht dem photosmart
verabredet für meinen instagram weil ich
dass wir so ein bisschen auffrischen
möchte ich habe hier noch sechs scheiben
gestern habe ich halt schon wirklich
viel gegessen jawohl man muss sagen wenn
man wirklich diese drei feste mahlzeiten
hat und auch nur brot und so und ich mal
zwischendurch legen wir noch was essen
kann ich hatte gestern abend echt hunger
hat aber ich hatte dann auch keinen bock
mehr hat und schon droht zu machen und
irgendwie hat es ja auch sonst nicht
zuwächst inwent gefragt also
normalerweise wenn ich auch deutlich
leckeres frühstück gewohnt aber das ist
ja wenigstens jetzt mal sehr gesund und
bin jetzt genau vier scheiben mehr gibts
ja anscheinend nicht nötig habe ein brot
nach einer freundin gegeben
um ehrlich zu sein hatten wir heute
morgen auch nichts anderes als dass
deswegen können wir da auch gar nicht
schummeln aber ich kann euch versichern
dass ich jetzt wirklich die letzten 24
stunden nichts gegessen und sagen wir es
mal so ich meinen viele menschen essen
ja einfach zum frühstück sondern käse
brot oder zum abendessen bin ich von
meinen eltern zu hause auch gewohnt da
gibt es hat so leute eben ist ja der
akku leer gegangen keine ahnung
irgendwie konnte ich mir auch nicht
vernünftig laden der jetzt schon wieder
abends also eigentlich ist das ganze
schon vor lang vorbei ich wollte dass du
noch schnell ein fazit ziehen und mal
kurz sagen wie ich das so fand weil wenn
man das jetzt eine woche macht dann wird
es wahrscheinlich noch mal viel viel
viel viel schwerer
ich habe jetzt 24 stunden gemacht ich
kann mir nur vorstellen wie sich das
anfühlt immer nur dieses dieses brot zu
kriegen oder diese kartoffeln und nie
wirklich ja auch noch was leckeres zu
essen wobei das ja auch gar nicht
unbedingt der fall ist weil man sich ja
alles möglich da auch irgendwie kaufen
kann also an sich war die challenge
jetzt überhaupt keine große
herausforderung für mich würde jederzeit
wieder machen kein problem
ihr könnt jetzt kann man die kommentare
schreiben was ihr noch sehen wollt also
24 stunden lang gibt auch gerne daumen
nach oben dann kommt bei 5.000 likes
nächste woche dienstag die nächste folge
und bis dahin soll ich sagen ich hab
euch hat das video gefallen und sofort
rein bleibt art ich mache keinen unsinn
dann müsste auch kein brot essen